they are all muscle operated so there
are actually no wires or anything
attached
you literally just slip your arm in and
as soon as i'm in there i can move the
fingers
so if i flex my muscles the hand will
open
and if i squeeze my muscles the hand
will close
[Music]
when i was born i was completely fine
happy healthy baby
um and nothing really seemed off at all
when i was 15 months old i basically
felt really really ill
with a disease called meningococcal
septicemia strain b
and it wasn't until my nana went to
change my nappy actually
that she found these kind of rash like
marks on me
my mom kind of describes it as almost
old age bruises
underneath the skin and that's basically
what they look like
and all she needed to do was like act
incredibly fast because
she'd read it and she just knew that it
takes life and it takes over your body
very very quickly
so she called the ambulance and
they were asking her questions and stuff
over the phone but she was just like
i'm sorry this is what i think it is and
i'll answer any questions just tell me
you're on the way and then she literally
scooped me up
and she was literally running to meet
the ambulance at the end of the street
because it's basically a battle with
time at that point and
i went i got to the hospital eventually
they basically took me in
i was transferred to a bigger hospital
and i was just basically told that i was
going to die
and my parents were told that i was
gonna die i was given what they said
zero percent chance of survival and yeah
that didn't really seem like there was
much hope for me
it literally got to the point where they
were going to shut my body down for the
machines to keep me stable
and they genuinely asked my family told
them to like go in and see me
because they couldn't be certain at all
that my eyes would open again
they knew what was intended was for them
to go in and almost say their goodbyes
but they went in but not with that
intention because they both collectively
knew like
this is tilly and she's not gonna die i
don't care what you say she's not gonna
die
so this was actually my first ever
prosthetic when
i think i got this when i was two years
old and this was from the nhs
when i got these first prosthetics we
were in the clinic
and it was handed to me in a brown paper
bag
and as if something to be like
incredibly discreet about
there was a woman when we were walking
away from the clinic
and she basically ran after us and she
just said
you know what that is the exact same
thing they gave to me 25 years ago
at the time and it hadn't changed the
function
how it looked anything at all but
there's basically three prongs and i
guess this is what was the thumb
and this hook basically attached to this
big harness and that would go
over my little two-year-old body and the
way i would move kind of my shoulders
and my upper arms
would pull on strings and make the
thing go side to side like almost like a
pinching movement
and i physically couldn't use it because
the strings were actually really really
hard to pull like my mom could barely do
it never mind a two-year-old
so when i was using this arm i
generally looked at it as more of a
weapon
than a hand i think i had more fun with
it like chasing my sisters around
pretending i was captain hook with it
and slapping them more than anything
else
so this was from a company called dulce
orthopedic
it's high-definition silicone and it's
actually based off of
my older sister's hands because sisters
are said to have similar hands
so my sister and like put her hand in
some goo
or something like that and they
basically mimicked all of her freckles
all their wrinkles and they have the
nails that you can paint
these are the ones i would wear out and
about but these were the same ones that
although they looked realistic they
moved incredibly robotically
and it was the same limited movement
where only kind of the foreman i think
these two fingers would like
open and close so yeah i think these
ones
were around the
36 000 pound point obviously there are a
lot of money
and i think the 36 thousand pound mark
that was like for the pair of them
but when i was getting them we didn't
not have that much money like
all the time so i would usually have to
pick which arm i wanted
and i remember i was always had a
massive preference for
the left hand you actually as a child
grow out of the hands and need to
replace them as you get older and
your arm gets bigger just with like
growth and age
when do you have a point where you first
notice
that something's different about you
compared to other children
when i got into primary school i started
to notice
the more kind of the reactions from
other people
and not only how i thought them but how
other people thought of them too
i found when i was wearing the extremely
high definition
realistic prosthetics when i was around
people that didn't know my story and
didn't actually know that they were
prosthetics
i would get a hell of a lot of stairs
more stairs than i would have done when
i wasn't even wearing hands and i didn't
have hands
because people honestly couldn't decide
whether the hand was real
whether it was fake like what it even
was because it looked so realistic i
would paint the nails on it and
everything and it had wrinkles and it
felt almost like skin
but then it moved so robotically i felt
like i always had to
wear these different prosthetics to kind
of blend in
and you're wearing it more for the
comfort of other people than yourself
what if we just went the complete
opposite way and it's something that i
never thought of before
i think because i was never told i was
allowed to think of it before because it
was always
just like yeah you have the realistic
prosthetics you're gonna look like
everybody else
maybe looking really realistic isn't
what i want
can you talk us through the process of
being chosen by the company to receive
the bionic arms
my mom had heard a bit about 3d printing
and
just out on a limb she was just like put
into google
3d printed prosthetics and bionics
because their hands are completely 3d
printed
and at the time they were a really
start-up company and they were basically
looking
for a child below the elbow amputee to
help them develop their prosthetics
and i'd had experience with other
prosthetics in the past building up that
muscle
i fit the criteria they were looking for
someone to help we were looking to get
back involved
i had loads of ideas i wanted to share i
guess you can say i kind of
auditioned for the role in a way i know
my mom sent them a picture of like me
dressed up as
alice in wonderland as my little promo
picture and
sammy who is the ceo one of the ceos of
the company
said like as soon as she saw me dressed
up as alice in wonderland she was like
that's the one
as soon as i got in with the company we
met them down in bristol
and they showed me around they got me
fitted with my own prosthetic home
and they were teaching me how to do it
and i think
i grasped the basics in a good five
minutes honestly
i think it's because obviously wearing
prosthetics my whole life and always
moving those muscles
it kind of just felt like second nature
to me at that point so a lot of people
do need like training
on how to use these hands using muscles
that they never had to use
anymore since they've lost their hands
or if they're born without the hands
they kind of forget they're even there
but since i was like
very well prepared and kind of that side
of it all
i was causing absolute chaos in the lab
to be honest like within the first 15
minutes i was
picking up these balls and like things
and just chucking them
across the window i know i whacked the
radiator at one point
there's one video that they have where
i'm like really really little i'm just
having so much fun like just chucking
things around
all right well this is a bit that we're
all waiting for would you mind giving us
a demo of them
yeah sure you don't mind the noise
okay basically how they work is they are
all
muscle operated so there are actually no
wires or anything attached
you literally just slip your arm in and
as soon as i'm in there i can move the
fingers
so if i flex my muscles the hand will
open
and if i squeeze my muscles the hand
will close
i think it's just the way that you
remove your organic limbs because
i can like see my hand moving on the
inside and it would be
the exact same way as like you closing
your face and opening your face i'm
doing a thumbs up
so the grip modes there are six in total
and it kind of looks like a menu system
so if i
flex my muscles to open the hand all the
way and then if i flex again i'm gonna
have you pay attention to the button on
the back
that turns green and there's a vibration
vibration on the inside of the arm for
me
and you would have seen the thumb come
around like that that's basically me
changing the grip mode so the phone
turns around and i could do a normal
tours like this
for say if you were holding maybe a cup
or a ball or anything like that
i can do a grasp this is definitely the
one i use the most um
high fives hand shaking it's also how i
hold makeup brushes in there because i
do makeup tutorials with my barnacles
and as well thumbs up that's pretty
important then if i press the button
it'll turn pink i now have access to two
more work modes
so that is the two finger pinch this was
kind of my signature pose for the
company for the longest time
i can do this which is called the tripod
grip
but i like to call it a peace sign
because i was using it as a peace sign
and you can also make those fingers go
down like that then
these are the two newest ones if i press
the button one more time
i can squeeze the muscle and do a tiny
pinch
and i've been in the lab working with
this tiny pinch and i can confirm
it picks up the tiniest beads like
hammer beads anything like that
you can pick up with that and then if i
flex one more time this is the last grip
kind of a bun um it's a point so i can
point like that and that can also go
down like so
is there anything that you wish your
arms could do oh there's loads of things
i wish my
arms could do it would be great to get
an automatic wrist at the moment there's
a wrist in these hands
and they are manual so if i just pull
it around like that you'll see there's a
wrist but it is only manual
um an automatic wrist would do wonders
for not only me but
everybody else i know because you don't
realize how much you use your wrist
every day so that would be incredible
also some kind of haptic feedback
whether that would be a vibration in the
arm when you've got a good grip on
something
or i don't know i don't know how this
works a lot of scientists i just have
the big ideas and
delegate um whether that would be like a
genuine sense of touch i don't really
know how that would work but
some kind of haptic feedback would
really really be helpful
so there's a lot of things i want to see
i still have
faith that all of them will become
reality and i feel like it's going to be
sooner than we all think
um i do a lot of like fashion and
talking about expressing yourself and
confidence and stuff
online on my social medias so like
instagram tick tock
um youtube you name it i love
to match my hands to my outfit
and like match it to my makeup or match
it to the mood like however i'm feeling
that day
and it's almost like now i look at my
bronycombs as not only a medical device
but almost a fashion accessory too like
a tool to totally express myself
and fashion accessory and medical device
is something that really are quite
contrast and i never thought i would say
in the same sentence but that's how it
is now
did you notice a lot more people
suddenly staring at you
yeah definitely i noticed stairs
but it felt completely different
like when i'm not wearing the hands
i'm just have my arms i don't have a
problem with stairs i'm
just used to it at this point that's
what you get when you go outside and you
look even the tintee is a bit different
so you just kind of get used to it um
but when i'm not wearing hands
um kids especially get like they're just
curious they're like
oh i've got hands she doesn't i think so
they want to go over and ask
but now wearing these vanicoms as you
can imagine
there's still plenty of stairs but it's
now not sympathetic at all like in the
slightest it's not
negative the reactions i get from
especially children
i think is just so much fun and not just
for me but all the other users that now
wear these bonicoms as well
kids see you in the street now and they
just think wow like they'll literally
shout at the top of the lungs ma'am look
at her hands why has she got robert
hands
but then the bit they'll put on the end
is where can i get my own robot hands
and that's something that you never hear
before
and this is my medical device and i
clearly have no problem with showing
that off like these are
diy from like a local business who like
land these cases up for me there
and we're just having a lot of fun with
it now my main message at the moment
is all about expressing yourself and
telling people that
if they look a little bit different that
they don't need to blend in
even if people have told them they have
to and that that's totally up to them
and they shouldn't like be influenced by
other people
or negativity or the past and history of
prosthetics
in any way because i just feel like you
control that and i try
to own my difference now and i encourage
my audience to do the same
if you could speak to somebody with the
same condition that you have that's much
younger
as just starting to be aware that
they're unique what would you say to
them
well i think the most important thing
for them to know
is that they're not alone in it because
i feel like i i do actually get a lot of
people
um a lot of like moms actually who
have their children and their children
are suffering from that disease and
they'll contact me because they will
have seen me on something
or they they've seen me on social media
before and
they'll just like ask any questions or
anything like that so i always encourage
any questions but
i feel like one of the main things that
i tell all these people
is that there's a much bigger community
out there than you might think
so don't ever think you're alone in it
and never let people tell you what you
can and can't do
that's a big thing for me because i was
told when i was in hospital that
i wouldn't be able to walk i wouldn't be
able to run i won't be able to play the
piano i won't even be able to live
so my parents actually went out of the
way to like buy a secondhand piano
and we're like if she wants to play the
piano she will play the piano don't tell
me what my child
can and will not be able to do and my
kind of motto in life
is we've all heard the saying look for
the light at the end of the tunnel
but i always try to say look for the
light within the tunnel
even if it's just like kind of a flicker
of a candle
like there's always got to be something
there that doesn't just go for people
who
are potentially limb different or like
me that goes for anybody
just for a more happier fuller life i
think
a lot of people who have tourettes tend
to report that they have fewer ticks or
none during sex
but the thing about that is that's
because it engages your focus
so that only applies to good sex which
is really
[ __ ] brutal because i've never hurt a
guy's ego more than simply going
during an intimate moment